est ce qu à tout hasard on en aurait pas
un peu marre d'être con aujourd'hui les
amis on va élargir notre culture
générale on va apprendre
incroyable nous sommes sur une vrai ou
faux un jury qu'elle va nous donner des
informations ils devront dire si c'est
vrai ou faux c'est la première vidéo de
culture générale sur cette chaîne c'est
parti le lac baïkal en russie et le lac
le plus profond du monde
bah ça commence bien bajeux faux et non
c'est vrai pour élire vos amis que vous
savez quel est le lac le plus profond du
monde
bon bah écoutez c'est reparti et en vrai
j'ai envie de faire cette vidéo parce
que moi je manque beaucoup de culture
générale et ça m'énerve
du coup j'espère qu'à la fin de cette
vidéo moi j'aurai la plus grosse culture
de france le mot book keeper et le seul
mot anglais avec trois doubles lettres
consécutive
ouais ouais ont déversé petit singe et
un plan est intelligent car ça toi une
semaine a porté plainte contre un
hôpital en disant qu'un scanner lui
avait fait perdre ses pouvoirs
psychiques
non mais ça c'est un truc il devrait
aller sur jeanmarcmorandini.com sympa
l'europe plus intelligente de savoir ça
écoute
ouais je m'étonnerai pas bon merci ses
pions pour toutes ces anecdotes dans
l'anglais anciens le mot je sais peut
les y ait eu
non je pense c'est du bullshit vous nous
prenez pour des cons la consommation de
thé est plus élevé que toutes les autres
boissons combiné incluant le chocolat
chaud le café l'alcool et les sodas mais
qui n'importe quoi c'est faux c'est sûr
mais c'est sur quoi mais c'est pas
possible tu prends juste tous les fast
food de la planète
les litres de soda qui sont consommés de
dents sont plus élevés aux litres de thé
consommer n'importe où ailleurs bon ok
ok ok petit panda taz saxon jamais aimé
le panda je propose qu'on allait faire
plein de câlins ces pandas pour leur
remonter le moral
le jeu guitar hero a rapporté plus
d'argent aerospace que n'importe lequel
de leurs albums
ah non ma réflexion a été vers courte
non aerosmith calme ils ont vendu des
palettes et palettes les 8 c à l'époque
d'acheter un coca t'es pas un album
aerospace avait qu'un pas mais d'un
autre côté il était un héros le jeu il
vendu 70 euros un album c'est quoi ces
15 20 euros
je pense que c'est vrai et c'est vrai
ouais tu as et darracq bien jouer
aerospace and now roues ça défonce bravo
alors à la naissance à un bébé pioche
fait la taille d'une puce puce
non je pense que c'est aller c'est vrai
c'est petite anecdote qui te laissent
leur vécu et aulas c'est dingue ça
taille d'une puce car le film le parrain
a été tourné à l'envers je crois que
c'est vrai j'étais totalement sordide en
salle à tous les mecs fans de cinéma il
m'insultait n'y a pas un film qui a été
tourné à l'envers bien dit pas dans les
commentaires ça me fera plein de
commentaires mais vidéo sera mise en
avant par youtube et choix point de vue
ça c'est fait alors le pringles man a un
nom et son nom et julio ce moment je
regarde les tableaux ce qu obama en
espagnol et j ça veut dire pringles man
on parle donc de la mascotte qui
n'intéressent absolument personnes sur
cette planète
ce gars-là rôle youth franchement il
avec sa moustache sa coupe moi je dis
ouais moi je dis que c'est vrai bah
ouais si ça vous étonne ac dc a fait 21
musique avec le mot rock dans le titre
vu le nombre d'albums qu'ils ont fait
j'y crois vrai
[ __ ] j'étais leur troisième chanteur
moléculaire m'en parle en lots est
beaucoup plus sec que le sable c'est
journal note que j'adorerais que mon
prof de chimie me donne et m'en donnez
jamais d'ailleurs quand un élément et
sec se dire qu'à peu de molécules l'eau
ch2o le sap cs4 b c'est vrai ça me
semblait possible bon c'est le problème
de ne pas avoir trop suivent les cours
de chimie c'est que tu oublies ce que
veut le dire certains termes techniques
tout ce qui reste de l'écriture de
shakespeare sont si signature et aucune
d'entre elle ne s'appelle shakespeare
comme ça franchement ça m'étonnerait pas
j'ai avec cbre aimerait y est c'est bon
à savoir ça donc en fait on orthographie
totalement balle le nom de ce mec
les fleurs de vanille fleurissent
pendant seulement un jour par annette à
sa sauce et nigel trop obvious que tout
le monde sait déjà tout vos parents vous
l'ont déjà fait j ai quand même que
c'est faux voilà merci papa merci maman
ne jamais avoir fait cette anecdote
merci 61% des chats préfèrent écouter de
l'opéra que de la kpop bon taf avec 12
août au chalet il a des goûts musicaux
donc est ce que ton chat est plutôt de
ce style
ou de ce style je pense pareil
moi je pense que l'opéra ça les rend
complètement ouf
donc je dirai jamais que c'est faux du
coup j'ai qui préfèrent la laque et pop
voilà et ben voila je savais au mexique
les artistes peuvent payer leurs taxes
en utilisant les hardcore qui l'ont fait
ouais je pense que c'est faux mais si
c'est vrai c'est absolument génial donc
je ne serais même pas déçu de m'être
trompé je pas déçu les tigres n'ont pas
d'eau doha ah bon c'est faux que c'est
une connerie ça c'est sûr n'importe quoi
igor layton a écrit son tube pro2 nhk en
seulement une nuit avec 40 de fièvre
c'est vrai c'est vrai j'y crois
totalement en cas de mauvaise conduite
la punition d'un policier thaïlandais et
de porter un brassard hello kitty sa
décribilise un petit peu la police
craint bref je pense c'est faux ce gamin
c'est vrai mais non c'est sûr jean marc
dubois comme ça en angleterre l'accent
anglais est différent tous les 25 miles
assez comme d'où l'accent du sud genre
marseille toulouse c'est pas le même
eux c'est ça mais tous les 25 miles je
crois que c'est vrai il me semble que
c'est vrai ça ouais merci papa maman de
me l'avoir dire jour un seul à ses
oripeaux comptèrent jusqu'à 20 milliards
de dollars de métaux par cette bande
sata et s'il fait deux fois la terre way
20 milliards non je pense pas non non
non c'est faux je pense les astronomes
guette le passage tout près de la terre
d'un énorme astéroïde c'est là doit se
passer dans dans les minutes qui moi me
teins fogel moi je partage et
l'astéroïde monnaies avez vous quelque
chose vient pas de cette vidéo sur vrai
ou faux geste face aux as plus c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais comme
d'habitude et c'est quand même pas mal
du tout on a appris pas mal de choses ça
fait plaisir
un suis habitué on n'apprend rien on est
des coûts si on fait une vidéo comme ça
une fois par mois pendant encore sept
cent vingt-huit années peut-être qu'on
pourra gagner aux 12 coups de midi le
jean luc là il sera sur le cul à la
tutelle projets biomasse avons regardé
portez vous bien john ging